- [Interviewer] All right.
So are we calling you Lay Low?
- Yeah, you can call me Lay Low.
- [Interviewer] Lay Low.
- [Lay Low] I had several
names at the time,
but Lay Low is one of the names I used,
I had Danno, I had No
Name, and I had Lay Low.
And the reason I used these names,
'cause I was selling a dangerous drug
called fentanyl, right.
When I first brought it down here,
no one would touch it.
I was living pretty dangerous,
'cause I was in a school zone,
and I had to change my name several times.
So everything I'm talking about
I already did time for it,
so it won't be offending to no one.
So I changed my names a lot of times
so the cops wouldn't know
who they was looking for.
They couldn't put the name with the face,
'cause I had over six blocks.
Nobody would touch fentanyl,
it's a very dangerous drug,
and subsequently everybody
who would touch it,
and they wasn't familiar with it,
they probably would die.
Fortunately I didn't get any bodies,
I made sure I distributed Narcan
to all the people who use it.
If they got out of prison and came to me,
I would never sell to them.
The most workers I had was like 15 workers
at one time,
I had six blocks,
everybody know me from here to Bakersfield
to Riverside, my name got pretty big.
And I was playing cat and
mouse with the cops a lot.
That's why I changed the name,
Lay Low, Danno, and Lay Low.
So they'd never know who
they was looking for.
Everywhere they go, I'd
be gone to the next spot,
because it's hard to hit a moving target.
So by me bouncing around
and doing different blocks,
I was making substantial amount of money.
That went away real fast.
I can say I made over $300,000 downtown
selling fentanyl.
- [Interviewer] Over what period of time?
- Less than a year.
I had a nice little run,
about eight, nine months.
I was going through
like, two or three kilos.
I had the cars, you know,
got my mom cars and jewelry and all that,
but she's the only one that
ended up with everything.
Not me, I ended up basically with nothing.
It's a hard pill to swallow,
because when you're used to having
that kind of money,
and then you go down to basically nothing,
you have to put your pride to the side.
It could destroy you.
- [Interviewer] It was the
conviction that did it.
- Yes, I lost everything.
I was married, wife was gone.
Reconciling with differences,
she locked up all the money I sent her,
which that's the only
person I could trust.
'Cause when you make money like that,
you have to trust somebody.
And she kept all the money,
and just divorced me.
They say when you're down,
sometimes they put dirt on you,
and that's what happened.
Especially when it come to drug money.
I lost relations with my kids behind that,
'cause I wouldn't stop.
They liked the money, but it
just wasn't worth it to me.
The only thing, the highlight of it is,
I sent my daughter to college.
I was able to get my
oldest daughter Candice
through college.
She's graduating next month as we speak,
she got her doctorate.
And that's a proud moment for me,
for being a drug dealer.
Everybody knows me down here,
I was pimping and selling drugs,
and doing all kinds of stuff.
But I was able to get my
daughter through college.
I did something positive with the money.
And she graduates next month,
she's been in college since she was 17.
She's 28 now, and for
the most part at first
I wasn't able to help her.
But I took her to the finish line,
and I'm a proud dad of that.
I don't know what's gonna happen,
I might not see you next month,
I might have a heart
attack like Fred Sanford,
something like that,
'cause it's a proud moment for me,
being a dad of five kids.
- [Interviewer] It's great.
So when you were selling,
you were selling just fentanyl,
or other drugs too?
- [Lay Low] I was selling
everything they wanted.
- [Interviewer] Everything.
- [Lay Low] Yeah, from women to ectasy,
crystal, fentanyl, cocaine, heroin,
whatever you wanted.
Each block consisted of something.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- [Lay Low] But my money
was in the fentanyl.
At one point, I was probably
the only one downtown
you could even get it from.
Five or ten dollars wasn't even an issue.
You had to have at least
fifty dollars or more
to purchase that.
It's a very expensive drug.
Now, they buying it for like five dollars.
So that's another reason I
wouldn't wanna get back in that.
- [Interviewer] And all of the drugs cut?
- [Lay Low] I had raw fentanyl.
You had to wear a mask,
and if you touched it,
it could kill you by the smell of it.
You'd have to have a mask,
and when you open it,
fumes go up, and it's just that strong.
It could kill you.
The stuff they getting down
here now is all cut up,
but I had raw fentanyl.
But like I said, I was
monitoring my situation
very carefully.
I didn't get any bodies,
that's the good thing about it.
- [Interviewer] Do you
tell your customers...
What's your role in the
chain of destruction
that goes on here?
(Lay Low chuckles)
- My role was to go count the money.
Keep up with the money.
I had the workers.
But I always informed
them to give them Narcan,
pass Narcan out,
because, Lord forbid, if you get a body,
you're pretty much done.
I don't think changing your name
would be able to save you.
'Cause fentanyl, like I said,
one smell without consuming
it could kill you.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, that's very...
- So my job was to get the money.
- [Interviewer] But do you
feel any responsibility?
When you put your head
on your pillow at night,
do you feel any responsibility
in what these people
are doing to themselves, and all that?
- Yes, extremely, man.
I had a lot of remorse about doing that.
When I did my time, I
had a lot of long nights.
Wondering what would happen to this person
or happen to that person.
Like I said, that drug
can destroy anybody.
- [Interviewer] Would you
introduce people to fentanyl?
- Never, I would never introduce somebody.
They had to be doing it already,
and if they just got out of jail,
they couldn't get none.
And I only allowed people that smoked.
If I found out you shot fentanyl,
I would not distribute it.
Nobody that used it intravenously.
'Cause it's for smoking,
but you can shoot it.
People use it for muscling purposes,
but the best way to do it is to...
They say smoking it.
That's the safest way
to do it, is smoking.
- [Interviewer] How'd you get arrested?
How'd you get caught?
- Somebody told on me.
Somebody in my circle told on me.
They got a case, and they told
them to give them somebody.
And so they did, and I was
getting ready to leave.
If I would have been smart
and left my money in the bank
instead of drawing it all out
and having a going away party,
'cause about a year a
half ago I was having
a going away party,
and they raided it, and they
got me for over $14,000.
And that was the last of Lay
Low pretty much right there.
That was my personal savings that I had,
and I drawed all the money
out all my bank accounts,
and I was having a going away party,
and they raided it.
They raided my house, my tent.
- [Interviewer] Going away?
Where were you going?
- Up north, Oakland, where my mom is.
I was just gonna go vacation, really,
but I was ready to quit,
because I had what you call
a tag on me.
And there were people assigned to me,
but like I said, by me changing the name,
they didn't really know who,
they couldn't put it together as of yet,
but that's why it's called investigation.
'Cause once they put it together,
like I said, they tied me.
I never got a direct sale.
I was very smart to not to
sell to anyone I did not know.
I didn't take third party money.
If someone that I know that
don't have this kind of money
bring that money to me, I would bury it
until later on that night, then I get it.
Because there's such a
thing as marked money.
That's one way they have to get you.
They gotta have the money,
the visual, and the drug.
I'm a critical thinker,
so I was pretty smart not
to let all those elements
catch up to me at one time.
And so when I got ready to go out of town,
they just mysteriously raided the party,
they found drugs, over
$14,000, and gave me
two years a half in prison.
I did it right there in
Los Angeles County Jail.
The worst time of my life,
the longest time of my life.
But with my influence on the street,
I was able to find a way up out of that.
'Cause you get a lot of favor,
and you meet a lot of people.
And I'm a people person, so
I buttered a lot of hands,
and I knew people.
So in there, I got a couple of jobs,
teacher's aide, went to school,
and got my time cut off like that.
I had favor everywhere I went.
Right now, today, people, they know me,
but I don't know them.
Just about anybody
downtown, they know Lay Low.
I put the mark down,
and I could say I had a
pretty good run with it.
I had my minute of fame in there.
I did something nobody else did.
I brought fentanyl down here.
Nobody would touch it,
they were scared of it.
I took a chance, and...
- [Interviewer] What
is... I'm sorry, go ahead.
- I won't say I regret it,
I just regret the people
that hurt theyself.
- [Interviewer] What is the
most popular drug currently?
- Right now?
Fentanyl.
- [Interviewer] Fentanyl?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] In the
'80s and '90s it was crack.
- '80s and '90s it was crack.
I had it running crack, too.
I started out selling
drugs when I was like, 15.
15 to 16, 'cause I had to
buy my own school clothes.
So my mom would tell me, "I'm
only gonna give you half.
You gotta get the rest."
So we had to figure out a way to do it,
and how we did it was
crack cocaine, you know?
Even in junior high and high school,
I sold crack cocaine.
It went from marijuana to crack to heroin,
and then when I found
fentanyl, I mastered the game.
Because I did it when I was young,
I just used all my elements
from then into now,
and I just supplied all my
rules to the same thing,
and it worked out just like that.
But eventually you gonna get..
You can't get away with it.
All good comes to an end.
- [Interviewer] Everyone
gets caught, right?
- Everyone.
Nobody gets away, unless...
Even the people that turn people in,
they get caught up too, eventually.
Just like they told on somebody,
somebody else gonna tell on them.
So it's just the same
game played in many ways.
And then when you don't do the work,
whatever they want you to do,
you're like a piece of trash anyway.
But one thing about me, I
always just did my time.
No conversation, I would never talk.
- [Interviewer] Did you use it at all?
- Yes, I was my best customer.
But I had so much, I was
buying a kilo at a time.
- [Interviewer] So you
were using fentanyl?
- Yeah, I was using fentanyl.
I'd use just about every
kind of drug it is.
- [Interviewer] Are you using still?
- No, not today.
- [Interviewer] So, how'd
you get off of fentanyl?
- When I went to prison.
- [Interviewer] When you went to prison.
- I had no choice.
But they give you a lot of pills, though.
They give you 10 or 15
pills that'll help you out.
Plus, I suffer from alcoholism,
and I was addicted to heroin and fentanyl
all at one time.
So when I went there,
they had on the computer
that I was a chronic user, high tolerance.
So they'd give me like 10 or
15 pills of the best stuff.
(Lay Low chuckles)
They give me Vicodin,
Klonopins, you name it.
They gave me all the good
stuff, 'cause I needed it.
I was in a lot of pain.
That's the worst kicking drug ever.
It's 10 times stronger
than regular heroin,
and fentanyl never lost the fight.
Nobody can beat it.
- [Interviewer] What are the chances
of you ever using again?
- Chances of me using it again...
Probably slim to none.
I'm 52 years old, I'm pretty much tired.
I drink my little liquor, whatever.
Hard drugs is just not for me.
I wanna live the rest of my life peaceful,
see my daughter graduate,
that's all I wanna do.
Fentanyl? Nah.
Too dangerous.
It'll kill you fast.
- [Interviewer] All right.
Lay Low, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
Very interesting.
- Yeah, that stuff, man...
It's too much.